e e
councelor I do have a question for you
before we begin uh do you think that the
quality of Law and Order has gone down
this
season I have to confess that I haven't
been watching uh I'm not invested in the
characters anymore is this an Alfred
play a noo play uh you know it's just
it's not the people I know and grew up
with on law order I want to watch it for
30 years and have the same people like
General Hospital uh so I did you have
brothers and sisters I I have brothers
okay so your response was what my wife
refers to uh in in me uh since I have uh
OCS only child syndrome oh if I want it
it should be that way but I agree with
you on this one all right I didn't know
that gave me away as having Brothers
yeah I can neither confirm nor
deny anyway thank you uh sure
thing you
ready
go open the committee meeting on the
special committee on the Family Division
of the circuit court and this will be
our last meeting together um in this
term maybe whoever a speaker next time
will choose to reup it I know some of us
think that would be a good idea and
maybe it'll happen we have three
subcommittees that met in calendar
2024 to continue the work that we did in
2023 you should have before you a
report of the subcommittee looking at
court communication was chaired by
representative Greg who sends her
regrets she's not feeling well today and
with representative ball who is uh
filling in presently as
Clerk and the committee members met
informally via Zoom with uh attorney
Erin krian from the courts uh you have
your report in front of you we reviewed
the case to tals that with a catalyst
for the committee Miss KGAN informed the
committee that because this case was
brought up in the special committee's
last meeting the courts have already
started to examine their Communications
and where improvements need to be made
let me say parenthetically as the chair
it has been a delight to work with the
courts they monitor what we do we came
in with the attitude of wanting to gang
up with the courts against problems and
not gang up against the courts which had
been done in some previous iterations of
this committee and as a result the
courts would hear things and say hey the
outside set of eyes uh are on to
something here let's go for it and
representative Greg is two for two in
not really having to do a heck of a lot
to convince because the courts were just
already convinced I think it's because
she she got named chair of both of those
subcommittees but that's an open
question while the particular case was
in the family courts their work on this
is included the entire court system at
the Supreme Court level they have
implemented a pilot program to include
direct texts with information about
court cases and you may have seen in the
news recently where the Supreme Court
chief justice has made a public
statement saying if you have anything
you need to talk with us about please
we're we're open we want to listen to
you uh back to the report at the circuit
court level they are working on a study
that includes how they handle motions
which can number in the thousands with
lengthy cases to see how best to deliver
Communications they are looking at a
possible change to rule 5.3 that would
ensure the delivery of new motions filed
attorney krian expects the study to take
three
months representative ball and I are
satisfied that the courts are aware of
and working to remedy the issue brought
to the committee we left the meeting
with an understanding that we would have
future corresponden from attorney KGAN
with the study results in their
Solutions there's the report anybody
wish to
comment representative Vice
chair thank you very much Mr chairman um
I I thank Representatives uh uh Greg and
ball for their their work on this um my
con I guess my concern is I want to I'm
curious as to how this will be
incorporated into the final report of
this committee since our charge is the
family court
not not um any other court
uh in in the Hampshire and
uh excuse me I think we should be
focused
on the family court in the work that we
eventually
submit to the
legislature am I being stuffy and
old-fashioned I do not take oldfashioned
as a negative term stuffy is
a
tossup I understand that but um I'm not
really the one to address those things
in the negative myself I would say it's
more than we need but it is adequate to
what we need that in saying it was in
the Family Court it is wider includes us
and since this is the report of the
subcommittee seeing no factual uh errors
or anything I would want us to includ
include this as
submitted thank
you representative
long thank you Mr chairman um
so uh they already started the courts
already started examining their
Communications was
that uh particularly the family court
or approach rep uh sorry for the insult
counc
attorney
krian good morning Aon krian general
counsel for the court system uh we did
we did a review of all of the courts so
I that this the Supreme Court finished
its review the Superior Court finished
we're still going through the circuit
court because there are a lot of motions
um to see if there's anything that we
think we need to adjust we did do a
training in the last week for all judges
all clerks on this case as a case study
to particularly flag this issue um the
issue that we were thinking is that
parenting CL cases close and then to
reopen them the person serves them again
so they know that the case is reopened
but in a guardianship it stays open
guardianship of a minor child um and
there's an annual report that's filed
and so what appears to have been the the
constituent experience is that a a
motion to terminate the guardianship was
filed and she did not get it didn't know
that it was coming didn't expect it um
that wouldn't happen typically in a
parenting case because there would be
that service that reopen opens the case
so what we were trying to look for is
another case like another instance where
that could happen that a case is
particularly long lived because it
involves for example the time that a
person's a child 18 years um that
something could be missed like that and
whether there was a change we need to
make but at a minimum we have trained
everyone on this particular issue
flagging motions to terminate
guardianship even without a rule change
I don't believe that set of facts would
recur okay now follow up five minut
follow up thank you
um so was was there conversation on uh
reporting to whether it's children of
family law I would assume um our review
was broader because whenever someone
raises that that there's a problem I
think we always want to see if there's a
bigger problem essentially so we did
look more broadly not necessarily
because the committee asked us to
because we thought there could be other
longlived cases where this could happen
um but to respond to the question that
was posed you know guardianship of a
minor child happens in the Family
Division it's certainly within your
jurisdiction um you know the the change
that we're thinking of making the
training that we've done is responsive
to the subcommittee which is within your
jurisdiction but could we decide we need
to make changes with guardianship of
adults in the Probate Court as a result
of this criticism or this this feedback
I think potentially but that wouldn't be
because the legislators were moving
outside of the the goal of um making
positive change in the Family Division
it would just be us learning uh that
there's potentially improvements to make
elsewhere great thank
you Vice chair
Smith thank thank you for recognizing me
again Mr chairman um could any of the
potential problem be related to the fact
that the court is not following the
rsas that um specify basically one one
case one
judge I
don't well the the the statute that
forms the Circuit Court establishes the
goal of one Court one judge but I think
even in the language there's
acknowledged that that is the intention
but there will probably be some
logistical challenges that come up
people will retire for example um you
know we may not be able to have one
judge one one family for um an 18-year
parenting case that that there just may
be logistical challenges with doing that
um so I I don't know that I see how that
comes into this particular issue which
was that a litigant did not have
information um I certainly think well-
trained and experienced judges are
always on the lookout for gaps in the
system or issues um the more we train
and prepare judges the more experience
they get the better they will be and the
longer they have experience in this area
but I'm not I I don't want to fail to
understand your question but I'm not
apprehending it a direct
connection thank you okay yeah good
would it be your testimony that
the uh law
itself speaks to the necessity sometimes
of wiggle room that is to say it is
aspirational it is our lofty goal to do
this but the law doesn't mandate I.E
judge Jones retires but there's this
still case pending he cannot retire
until this case is done uh the law
recognizes itself that there will be
mitigating circumstances is that your
teston it it sets a goal of one judge
one family and we certainly have that
goal because judges become very invested
in the families that they serve and it's
generally good I think you see
particularly in smaller cour houses that
the judge sees everything that might be
the only judge that sits there they see
the parenting case they see the criminal
case where they see the a DV case they
see all the connections in the community
of what's going on we can't necessarily
have that in every Court some courts are
larger than others but the more the
judge knows about what's going on with
the family uh you know what's going on
in the community the more effective they
are so it's certainly the judge's
preference as well to to stay with the
same cases follow up it would be then
your testimony that in your opinion the
judicial system is not actually in
breach of the law here
the law is a
goal as opposed to a mandate which could
be disobeyed perhaps but it is not
disobeyed here it is the best we can do
it is our goal and if we don't do it it
is not actually in breach of the law as
written is that your testimony it it is
absolutely not Our intention to violate
any law but we run into other laws
there's a mandatory retirement age for
judges that was a leading
question and and I'm answering it with a
speaking answer answer but there are
other laws that were Bound by for
example mandatory retirement ages for
judges so we don't have um flexibility
on every point but we we certainly
Endeavor to honor the spirit the
legislature has determined that that is
policy it is a good uh reasonable ask
that we want to implement but there are
logistical challenges any questions from
other committee Members
First seeing none Vice chair Smith thank
you I I don't want to get into
um a debate
with my colleagues or with the council
but I think using the um issue of
mandatory retirement age as your uh
explanation might not be totally
accurate um in that there would be few
if any cases where the
reason that um there is more than one
judge is because of mandatory retirement
age much more likely I think and much
more frequent is
um are many other reasons including
dockets and assignments to more than one
Court um and other decisions that are
made without regard to what I would hope
would be a guiding principle of of
one one case one judge but
um as I say I don't want to get into a
debate about that well you're you're
certainly right representative there are
many issues that that example I give
simply because it is a constitutional
mandate so it is not something we can
countermand but you're right there are
many other logistical challenges that we
have in particular training and bringing
up to speed a large number of new judges
has meant shifting some Personnel around
from different courts
um some judges start in Manchester so
they can be near other judges and get
more experience so you're right that's
certainly not the only challenge there
are
many anyone
else once again a leading question
um as I read and the committee members
are looking at the um report from
representative
Greg uh that indicates the courts are
looking widely and not just at Family
Court is it your um testimony that while
the courts may be looking more broadly
than at Family Division they are not
neglecting looking at Family Division
therefore this report answers the charge
that I gave the subcommittee to examine
this issue I will I will leave the
question of uh of the legislative charge
but we are absolutely evaluating the
Family Division large number of
self-represented litigant appear appear
there we want to make sure that um the
system is working for them there but
there are certainly lessons from other
case types for example we're starting a
pilot program very shortly to use text
messaging notification in criminal cases
in uh Rockingham County if that's
successful we would potentially broaden
that to other areas so we we do have a
little bit of cross-learning from
different case types thank you so much
any further
questions thank you for your testimony
representative Lynn if you could pass
back a copy of this and also of your
report I mean there were extras and they
must have landed in front of you so if
we could have the stash why don't we
have the stash back and I will deposit
them with the
clerk and uh okay we have yeah we're
doing this one
uh the chair moves that we accept this
subcommittee report from representative
Greg uh is there a second representative
long any final
discussion is saying none would the
clerk or assistant clerk please call the
role on the subcommittee looking at
court
communication chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman
Smith yes representative Lynn yes
representative ball yes representative
lonza yes representative cab votes yes
representative long
yes that's seven years 70 this report is
accepted uh to be placed with the
interim report that discussion will take
place later but um that's what where
what's going to go now I open um look at
the subcommittee on perjury
representative former Chief Justice Lynn
chaired this with a number of people I
was privileged to sit in on it uh
representative Lynn would you give us an
overview of your report please sure um
basically um the issue was um
was the
problem uh of of perjury in family law
cases uh and what are the remedies for
that and um based upon the information
we received during the the hearing on
this matter it appears that there are
ample remedies
available uh for perjury and for lesser
uh offenses and in fact um based upon
the testimony of Mr valard uh an
Assistant Attorney General who has
Decades of experience as uh the county
attorney and previously an assistant
County attorney in straford county and I
I would add probably one of the most
respected uh County attorneys in the
state
um he indicates that that you know that
that perjury is something that is uh is
is prosecuted regularly including uh uh
in some cases uh arising out of family
law uh situations and he and he also
mentioned I think importantly that um
perjury uh the basis of perjury claims
uh uh May uh may be not only a referral
from the attorney general's office or a
prosecutor um but also from people who
are involved in family law cases um I
think he indicated that there were at
least uh some cases that he was aware of
where a referral had been made by a
litigant or perhaps a witness or
something in a family law case that
ultimately resulted in uh a perjury
prosecution he also emphasized however
that uh both perjury and even the Lesser
uh uh uh misdemeanor level offenses
involving false statements um are not
easy cases to prove there has to be uh
proof that a false statement was made
that it was made knowingly that it was
made without
believing uh that the that the statement
was true uh and that it was something
that that was not sort of Simply a you
know a mistake or a misperception or an
opinion as to something as opposed to
um a clear-cut lie um about some about
some factual matter um the one issue
that was raised that um uh I think the
committee thought might might uh Merit
some further uh action on the part of
the Judiciary is uh the suggestion was
that it was not that some people
involved in family law cases may not be
aware of the available remedies of
perjury or other types of false
statement offenses and that perhaps um
in Publications that the judicial branch
uh provides for litigant that that um
that more uh a more robust statement of
the availability of those remedies
should be available and that seemed to
the subcommittee to be something that
was worthwhile um exploring and I think
the judicial branch um was not was not
opposed to doing that attorney krian if
you had not just done that would you
write that down please for me I think
you just probably did our running list
of what's going in the guide
book that there are here are the
remedies yeah thank
you um
any questions for representative Lynn on
his report on
perjury I have one of of you
representative would it be your
testimony
that one of the reasons maybe more
reasons but at least one of the reasons
we have heard from numbers of people
when we took testimony last year that
there were downright lies going on in
that court and nothing was done about it
was that the people making those
statements a do not know the difference
of maybe of a downright lie versus a
misapprehension versus something else
and B they didn't know the remedy they
could have used and that's why some at
least people would feel angry that there
were lies and nothing happened sure I
mean that that certainly could be one of
the reasons I think the other thing that
is is
really very very important to understand
is and I can say this you know
unquestionably from my own
experiences the basic
remedy for
perjury um in in most not only in family
cases but in most in most cases is that
the FactFinder if something is perjury
the fact find the remedy that the
FactFinder May impose is they simply
don't believe the person um and whether
you know I can I mean just again from
personal experience I can remember any
number of cases in which I felt that
somebody um was uh was probably not
telling the truth um and so the remedy
that I impos is I was just not going to
base a decision on that person's version
of the facts and often I would conclude
it's just not worth it to refer this you
know this person uh to a prosecutor for
criminal prosecution be for example
particularly in a family case um it it
it might I might well come to the
conclusion look if I refer this there's
enough contention going on in this case
already um I somebody I think somebody
has lied to me I'm not going to base a
decision on what I what I believe to be
uh untrue testimony I'm going to make a
decision based on what I believe is true
testimony but it's not worth it to refer
this person for prosecution because
that's just going to increase the level
of tension in the family relationship
more than it already is if somebody ends
up getting prosecuted now that's not to
say that's all always true sometimes
some perjury can be significant enough
on a matter that's really very important
and I would make a referral but often it
would be that you would simply decide
not to not to make that referral because
it would just be more it would be it
would be more trouble so to speak than
it was worth in the overall scheme of
things when you as a judge were faced
with that and something was offered that
you clearly deemed in yourself to be a
lie uh and you wouldn't use it in making
your decision was there a way that you
let the people know that otherwise they
might think that lie was allowed to
influence you if they don't know to the
contrary sure again it depends on this
you know so much depends on the
circumstances but often you know again
if it was particularly blatant I might
simply say you know this I do I did not
believe this person's testimony but
often it would be again for the same
reason I just pointed out to try to you
know keep the the Discord in the family
um at as at as at as a reduced level as
possible I might simply say something
like you know there was there was
disputed testimony on this point and I
find the I find the facts to be okay in
support of the person that you know that
I that I thought was telling the truth
um without sort of really trying to tag
the other person as being a liar any
further questions for representative
Lynn on his
report representative long thank you Mr
chairman um was there any consideration
as to like let's say I I filed against
my exp spouse
um I told what I thought to be the truth
the police and was later determined that
that's not the fact however I kept that
fact up was there any um I mean like if
a judge says like you would mention
right I believe this litigant um but if
if the if what you didn't believe is
still being brought up is there any
further I mean is that
allowed when you well when you say if
it's when you say it's it continued to
be brought up in other words you mean
that like at some later per some later
stage in the proceeding right um sure I
mean that might you
know that might be something that would
would in
would weigh a judge to say maybe I am
going to make you know I've I've
rejected this once this person you know
kind of didn't get the message um and
now is tried to you know raise the same
thing again sure that might lead you to
say okay maybe maybe something stronger
does need to be done now to okay you
know so yes I think the answer is yes
thanks Vice chair Smith thank you um if
I could ask an another question of my
distinguished chair is this possibly an
example of a problem that
arises when we have more than one judge
handling a particular case so that's
something where you could clearly see
uh that there was inaccuracy in the
testimony that is not necessarily that
knowledge is not
necessarily um available to another
judge mean that that is absolutely
correct you I mean that's that is that
is one of the most important reasons I
think that it's that it's it's crucial
and I I completely understand what what
attorney krian said and I I agree that
you know
unfortunately there are sometimes when
other considerations prevent you from
having from Strictly sticking to the you
know one family one judge I understand
that but I think you what you point out
is really a very uh important reason for
having one judge be involved in the case
because it's you know when I first went
on when I first went on the Superior
Court we had we had the we had the
situation of where there was no well
except maybe in homicide cases but other
than that there was no assignment uh no
practice of one you know one case one
judge and so judges moved around a lot
and you know this C on on on one month
the case would be heard by judge X and A
month later something else would come up
it would be heard by judge Y and then
the third month judge Z and it was that
kind of situation encouraged litigants
who you know to try to you know that I I
well I threw this I threw this piece of
baloney up against the wall with judge X
and it didn't work but now there's a new
judge and maybe it's worth throwing that
same piece of baloney up against the
wall because maybe I'll be able to
convince the new judge that it's true
whereas you know if you had if you had
more consistency in the judges it would
be presumably there would be less
incentive to do something like that so
you you rais an excellent excellent
point about one you know why it's so
important to have one judge assigned to
a case whenever possible I would like to
uh I was in the process of texting but
he stopped so come on
up attorney kigan is it possible given
we cannot have a
100% one case one judge for reason cited
is it possible legally for a judge to
make a note in the judge's notes that
the next judge picking up the case would
have to say I thought the testimony of
such and such was baloney or some other
legal term from French
law uh so I I think the way that judges
typically memorialize things in their
case is two ways and that's written
orders and and their verbal statements
because there isn't really
um anything outside of that that should
give the person in the complete case um
you know we have we have an oral
tradition um in the United States that
very much puts the emphasis on
everything coming out in the proceeding
and if not then in a written order so
that you have the complete record what
has happened in the case through those
available means so there is not a side
Ledger that really keeps notes that
would be passed but I I think you do see
judges note on the record you know you
have not been found credible or in
orders say you know I've I've I've heard
this
testimony this this testimony was
credible this testimony was not so that
would typically be where you would find
um a judge's appraisal a judge's notes
about a case is in their written orders
or in their verbal statements in open
court representative Lynn do you think
that the judge in question here x uh
judges X are doing this more than some
years ago as a way of mitigating a
second judge coming on or is there
something that we could encourage to
have this information passed along yeah
I I I mean I again I think it it sort of
depends on the circumstances I think if
a Jud you know if a judge really thought
something was was kind of blatant
baloney um more likely that the judge is
going to put in the order put something
in his or her order saying you know this
this argument was made by this litigant
and you know it it it has no uh it has
no uh credibility or whatever and I'm
rejecting it and of course then that
would be available for uh for the next
judge but again is you
know sometimes if it's more if it's more
subtle uh maybe that doesn't get doesn't
get put in um but I I guess I do also
agree with Miss crean I think it's um
the I I I would have difficulty or
trouble with the idea of Judges kind of
writing little you know notes that are
not available sort of side notes that
are not available to the public to
say you know other words I think our our
legal tradition in this country is that
judges speak by their orders that that
become public records and not by little
you know little side notes and so I
would I would wan to
uh I would not encourage that kind of
thing representative
cab I did want to note that we did find
thank you Mr
chairman I did want to note that we did
find when we were first going through
this that when the family court was
established back in 2005 right from the
gecko 490d did specifically state that
the intent was to have the assignment of
all family matters of a single family to
one Family Division Justice or marital
Master located in a family court that's
geographically accessible to the family
so I think that has always been the
intent of the general court here that we
we wanted that to
happen is there a way
of kind
of really pressing that that really
needs to happen because it I think it is
important that we've heard from families
that have now gone through five
different judges I understand that a
judge may move away or retire and there
may be a circumstance but I think it's a
whole separate thing when on a regular
basis it's happening that we're just
flip-flopping between judges is there a
way to make it more stable for
families I think that's a great question
one of the challenges we've had is just
this overturn of a very large generation
that we have in public service generally
but certainly in the court as judges um
that some of the those judges are
willing to stay on um and and keep some
of their complex and long running cases
as judicial referees and and continue
working them but sometimes not and we're
bringing up a a large a relatively large
number of newer judges and there is some
shuffling to the places where there are
gaps and then there is some people who
are assigned to be in multiple locations
in order to make sure that the court is
open on those days and there's a judge
available I know that it was certainly
it was something I discussed with um
judge king a lot before uh the end of
his term that he really wanted to get
to a place of more stasis once we had
more of a settlement with the the new
judges of this is your court it's your
court for a very long time um you know
if if this person is mid-career as many
of these judges are they could be a
judge for 30 years um and they could see
a family all the way through to the Next
Generation uh so I know that that was
certainly his hope uh three more judges
have just been nominated bringing the
Circuit Court to 49 when if they are
confirmed uh that that would be the way
to achieve more stasis is not having
this sort of generational overturn that
we've had in the judges um and bringing
on so many people who will have
hopefully long careers um in the
Judiciary uh it is it is always a little
challenge for different reasons but that
was something that he thought was a
particularly bad epic for us because of
that turnover and that the hope is that
it will not be people's experience to
the same extent that it has been that
they see changes in
judges thank you and we are on the
subcommittee on perjury let's uh try not
to revisit some things we have have
already discussed and conveyed uh
anything else on the report on perjury
representative Lynn's
report any further
questions uh would somebody move the
acceptance of the report representative
Lynn it's yours I'll I'll I'll make that
motion all right
second representative long getting in
all of his House of Representatives
motions on his way to to those people
that shall not be named on the other
side of the wall after the next election
I'm not jinxing
you thank
you when the clerk is ready please call
the role the motion is to accept the
report on the subcommittee on perjury
moved by representative Lyn and seconded
by representative long chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman Smith yes
representative Lynn yes
representative ball representative lonza
yes representative cab votes yes
representative long yes representative
McBeth yes Z 8
Z 8 to Z the report is accepted we will
consider it when we consider our final
vote the next uh report is a
subcommittee of Representative
kab one for
you is her report this is the
subcommittee on title four the Social
Security Act specific to the state of
New Hampshire this was an issue that uh
chairman Jess Edwards of division three
of Finance late of Health and Human
Services committee was keenly interested
in and uh suggested this be something
important to our work with family court
representative katab would you make your
report
please unfortunately representative
Edwards uh wasn't able to come to either
of the meetings so we didn't get to hear
kind
of from him on this however we did we
did look into this
and representative Smith was able to get
a nice audit report which is included on
the back showing
really the information that we were
looking for which was how how why and
where all of
the title four relative to the Social
Security Act funding goes in New
Hampshire and it was pretty minimal in
the area of Family
Court Family Court really only gets
involved with title title four to
establish uniform support order when
establishing paternity when necessary if
a party is refusing testing the
modification of the support
orders every 3 years or earlier if
there's significant change in
circumstances and then show cause
hearings and then in Superior Court
there's a criminal uh nonsupport cases
through the Superior Court which are
very rare and there's less than 10 of
those a
year through this we did discover that
there's an
automatic assignment of income wage
garnishment even if the parties had
always been a paying on time unless the
parties had agreed otherwise or if there
was good cause not to require it and
there was concern that wage garnishment
could affect somebody's employment it is
something that you do have to fill out
on a background check and whatnot and
there might be some bias that if
somebody's having wage garnishment
people may presume wrongfully so that
the person is a deadbeat so to speak
because they're not they must not be
paying which is just completely untrue
because this is just happening the
majority of the
time upon further looking into it this
was actually required by federal law La
that this be the presumption and if we
aren't compliant with it then we
wouldn't be eligible for not only title
defunding but also title A and E funding
as well which approximates to about
19 uh million do a year and it just
wouldn't be something that we likely as
a state could afford to to forego and be
like we're not going to follow this this
Federal requirement so while we do note
that it's an issue upon further looking
it seems as that at this point all 50
states and four territories are all
except ing of this and so I think it
really if it's something that needs to
change needs to change more at a federal
level um and so that was where we kind
of landed on this title four stuff and
again all the
detailed findings in here are in the
back your operative uh charge to us or
recommendation is the last paragraph of
the first page uh I would assume that
you do not recommend any change at this
time and you did not discover any issues
relative to title
4 so at this time we didn't recommend
any state leg legislative changes
because again this was a federal thing
we also noted that hb564 relative to the
child support guidelines had just passed
and it doesn't go into effect until
January 1st and so we feel that it's
important that we see how the impl
implementation of that implementation of
that legislation goes before considering
a further change to that I think it's
really important that
we we need to see how that's going
before we we get into further changes
that hasn't even been enacted yet so
um any questions of Representative katab
representative mcbath and sorry for not
recognizing you earlier to to come on in
and sit down it's been a rough week and
my mind is flitting about okay well
thank you for recognizing me now thank
you um representa to my question is um
these is there anything we can do to
prevent I don't know who is what
employers are requiring the background
checks but uh I mean requiring the
information that garnishment be on a
background check but if it's the state
we certainly could change it so that
that question isn't asked um I mean if
we're you know if it if we know that
it's a federal law and it's a
requirement State too I mean that that
child support is garnished then why
don't we address that issue and not
allow that to be a um a request for
information when people are employed
being employed um May I yes thank
youman so essentially a lot of it was
coming up on federal background checks
like if you were get getting a security
clearance so obviously we couldn't get
into that it does usually it does state
are you having wage garnishment for any
reason and then it allows you to explain
so the person can explain it I suppose
on I could look at the state background
check form and see I think it would
still be a question where the reason
that I because I did spend some some
time looking into why the question is
asked and the reason why the question
was asked was if you are having wage
garnishment because you weren't paying
something then it's thought of that you
may be more of a liability more likely
to be able to be bribed so to speak in
in any and and that's relevant to
several type of type of jobs where you
want to make sure that this person isn't
isn't hurting for money so to speak and
might be more likely that they may be
more bribable so to speak and so that's
why the question ends up being asked so
I guess maybe on state forms it could be
asked if it was for non-payment the
question could be changed to say are you
having W wage garnishment because of
non-payment
maybe
followup thank you so I appreciate that
I I that that's an area I think that we
might want to pursue further um even
having um a statute that says you know
this is our policy and it cannot be used
against um you know uh people that are
applying for jobs um even on a form
because it seems like there's a
significant amount of people that are
going to have to say yes I'm my child
support's garnished and a very small
amount of people that actually the
question would be relevant for so um I
appreciate your work on this it's very
significant and I um but I recognize the
issue and I think the state could do
what it can to not ask the question if
it's not relevant or to ask the relevant
questions um and also to maybe be clear
this is the state's policy you know
we're going to be garnishing wages just
because it's easier whatever thank you
representative
ball thank you excuse me thank you
chairman Pearson and I truly do
appreciate uh representative MC Beth
what you bring forward um I do have some
concerns though in going in that
direction because this in particular
happens um is a concern when we're
hiring police officers and if they are
have a questionable Integrity um because
they're really not paying their um child
support then it could mean that as we
said they could be easily bribed they
could lose evidence there's so many
things that could um hurt people in
other ways I I'm looking at this and
wondering why can't we use the caveat
that's given to us by the federal
government that says if the judge
determines that there is no reason for
it then there doesn't need to they don't
need to have it it's written in the
federal law we have a caveat that if we
were just to
say whether it was the marital um
magistrate I forget what you call them
um or the judge make sure or an attorney
make sure that the people are aware of
the possible ramifications of signing up
for this versus if you're paying on time
you've never had a problem you could
continue in that manner um because that
is allowable under the way the the way
that I read the federal
law so I can Beth yes go ahead respond
but these are initial orders so there is
not experience of whether the person has
paid or not and just for me my
preference would be that it was taken
out that I never I mean so
again I understand what you're saying
it's just a different philosophy but I I
think further looking at it would be a
good idea and maybe for police officers
if that's such a signif or for certain
report I mean for certain um employers
but again I just bringing up I I I don't
you know thank
you representative ball thank you it
does go beyond police officers it goes
into um top secret clearance for
military and
um institutions and things for anybody
getting any type of top clearance
what is the will of the committee do we
accept the report as written with the
statements we've made noted in the
clerk's report that at some point uh
somebody may wish to file legislation on
this or is it the committee's desire to
add a sentence or two to the report as
submitted to
us
may represent
long thank you Mr chairman uh yeah I I
accept uh I was at the meeting and I I
was fully satisfied with uh with this
report and how to address um somebody
can bring in further legislation to
address the jobs where gunishment may
hurt you I know uh Clarence at seor
nuclear plan that was also question that
I was asked that question when I worked
here any anyone
else representative katab thank you
chairman peon I guess I would be a
little hesitant to put that into the
report right now unless we can actually
research and find out that that is on
the state background check because I
haven't check explored that I do know
that it was on the security clearance
check that was a federal but I'm not
sure from a state level I'd be certainly
open to that sort of legislation but I'd
want to make sure that we're
recommending something that is relevant
I did try and just do a quick search and
I wasn't able to find it that quickly
okay uh that would be my only hesitation
is that I want to make sure whatever
we're putting in here
we've vetted but I would absolutely be
supportive of a bill if we were a if we
did find out that that was happening I'd
definitely support
that so accepting this report is not
with prejudice against anyone else
taking this and running with it should
he or she
choose okay uh our chair will entertain
a motion to accept your report so moved
moved by representative katab uh
somebody second representative long when
the clerk is ready please call
ly I'm sorry I just wrote
long those L names it is they can be
confusing
absolutely yeah and a double n at the
end
uhe um chairman Pearson yes
representative Smith yes representative
Lynn yes representative ball yes
representative lonza yes representative
cab votes yes representative long yes
representative McBeth yes 8 Z report is
accepted 8 to zero the next item before
us and you should have gotten this is a
little something that we might wish to
put um in the report and it is very
self-
congratulatory new laws passed because
of testimony before our special
committee
um here's some things that
happened because of our first year of
work uh some of the discussions led to
the Judiciary actions some of our
discussions led to lsrs fil turned into
bills and passed and signed so just take
a read over this and think is this
something we might wish to put at the
end
could I ask a question of the share
while people are reading this you
could please ask your question thank
you may I yes you may thank
you I want to take two Giant Steps um
I'm looking at the time I know you have
a 10:30 meeting scheduled I'm wondering
when we are going to see a draft of the
full final report to vote on oh in about
5 minutes
thank you welcome good
question and thank you for your concern
about my other committee or at least one
of
them representative long thank you Mr
chair um yeah I think uh representative
katab had a good idea of also entering
these three bills that uh we could we
could fit so I would move that these be
added to the uh report thank you you
know while while many reports oh that
was a motion sorry uh you are moving
except this to the report um okay that's
long with one n yes yeah thank you uh um
a
second small I'm
sorry Lynn with two ends okay the the L
CR now we can have discussion and um as
we know there have been uh
various groups
in various levels of
[Music]
formality addressing family
court and some of them having read all
the reports including a few little ad
hoc Gatherings let's just say I think
it's very helpful going forward
to the next time this sort of special
committee is convened to say darn you
know when you cooperate and get good
things done and I think that's what this
document um and thank you for this uh
has done any other comments on new laws
passed document yes representative
McBeth so thank you um so I
I think it's well written as far as the
description of the bills I'm I'm a
little bit more humble I think or modest
I don't know that we should say laws
passed because of the testimony and it's
just semantics I mean I recognize the
the Decades of people behind us and
other members that have worked on these
issues and pushed them it's like the the
toothpaste might have come out when we
squeezed it but or when we got testimony
but there's a lot of people that have
worked in the past so i' kind of like to
change maybe the
title of the of the make a suggestion
because I've got one if you don't all
well let's let's hear yours and then
I'll discuss it thank you new laws
passed in
part because of the test
imy of this in part takes some credit
where credit is due but doesn't take all
the credit other
suggestions representative
um I would
suggest in
part and uh representative long and Lynn
would you withdraw the motion and make a
motion to new laws passed in part
sure sure I'll second that yeah all
right good so there's the motion as
amended passed in part and thank you for
that
um you know I'm aware of Winston
Churchill's comment about Clement Atley
when Churchill who was not known for
modesty was told you should be like
Clement Atley he's a modest man
Churchill he has much to be modest
about um yeah any further discussion
clerk please call the role on this
document chairman Pearson yes
representative Smith yes representative
Lynn
yes representative
ball representative lonza yes
representative cutab votes yes
representative long yes representative
McBeth yes e to eight zip now the final
document before us is the report uh the
interim report of um this
committee as of November 20th of last
year and we voted on this so this was a
done deal in fact it was a done deal
reading the report of and when we
decided we're having so much fun let's
keep going and I can pretty much in part
convinced you of that uh that led to the
work we just did so what you have before
us is a done deal doesn't mean we can't
change it just don't please nitpick it
uh we we had that time and I suggest
that
supplementing that
are the three subcommittee reports we
just unanimously voted and the final
self- congratulatory thing which as
amended we just voted and we put them
all together and that would be our final
report now there were were additional
documents
supplied as I recall that I don't see
attached do I see them attached I don't
see them attached but they were voted on
right they weren't voted on so the only
way uh today this morning we can vote
those supplemental documents is either
by us seeing them and voting on them or
by someone suggesting can we have the
report on and we take that as sufficient
and choose to vote Yes representative
katab thank you chairman P so when we
did this initial report we had discussed
that this was just kind of a draft in
there and that we weren't going to worry
about
putting uh a lot of the attachments in
here which was relative to the research
that was done by the committee
researcher on several of the topics I do
really feel like it's important that we
summarize the majority of issues that
were brought up and then put in the
research that was done on those issues
so that we're not Reinventing the wheel
should somebody pick this up in the
future and I do feel like it's it's
especially important where we did pick
certain areas that we were going to do
subcommittee topics on but there were
some that we didn't that that were in
fact issues just to document them
somewhere I do feel like we need to have
some sort of an
overall
um piece in here that summarizes you
know hey several parents complained or
were concerned about the one family one
judge issue there was also the domestic
violence issue so there I think there
were several pieces that are important
that we list
out I would suggest that the committee
refer back to some emails I sent out two
three and four weeks ago to the effect
that if you have some stuff send it to
me and I didn't get a lot of stuff so if
there's reports that somebody wishes to
be included in this final report I don't
see them in front of
us chair can um I think Vice chair um I
representative Lynn was first okay you
want to throw fingers or paper scissors
no can I just make a I just I just throw
this out as a suggestion could we
say that we are could we basically have
a motion that would say we are going to
adopt the interim
Report with the three subcommittee
reports and the um the uh backpacking
backpacking report
uh page that summarizes legislation that
was passed in part because of this as
our final report and we are going to
include as attachments to the final
report all the materials that were
presented to the subcommittee um that
were presented to the committee um
you know I will consider those that
those will be considered as attachments
and we
be attached to the final report I assume
since I was I was not in right the I was
not a member of the committee when those
uh earlier uh submissions were made but
I assume if we've if they were submitted
and they were you know and they're
they're sort of in the record there's no
reason we couldn't just attach them to
the final
report any further discuss question on
representative Lynn's Point
representative Vice chair Smith Smith
thank you um
I I agree in principle with what
representative
Lynn has just propose but I think we
have to be more specific about what we
mean when we refer to materials
submitted we had um file draws for
of materials submitted and that I think
is not the the
definition that would work best I think
we could talk about the research that
was done by our
staff as a more um
focused uh identification of uh the
materials that we used and I said say
that because in in good faith and
certainly out of concern we had many uh
Witnesses come and present to
us
um
enormous
quantities of
um the cases that they have had before
the family court and I think that
material belongs to the family court not
to the
legislative branch which is why I worry
about that but I also am concerned about
um the conclusory sections for example I
do see in here reference to the need for
um Education and Training I do see some
reference to the import importance of
the statutory language of intent of one
family one
Court um but uh there are there are
other other uh basic arguments that we
have made
um that are not in here one that to me
is I think one of the most important
is rather than a need for new
judges given um a limited amount of
Financial Resources I believe that the
judges in this court
need what in other courts could be
called clerks or could be called um
assistance you I I don't I'm not going
to dictate what the title is but judges
need
support and they need support in
recordkeeping they need support in
producing um uh their
findings they need support so that uh
claimants do not have to wait for weeks
or sometimes months to get a decision
not because the judge is being um
irresponsible but because there are so
many hours in the day Madam Vice chair
I'm going to stop you there because uh
we have discussed this and this has been
conveyed to the courts they agree with
us this is aspirational and they are
trying to get it out of the next budget
in a year where they may not get much
but I think everybody agrees with this
well if everybody agrees Mr chair then
it ought to be listed in the report in a
way that reinforces how important that
is it is we are not negotiating here
with the courts I appreciate the help
that Council kigan has given to us but
this is a legislative committee where
would you put this in the report I would
put it first not point point to it to
us Mr chair I'm not going to second
guess you and I'm not going to sit here
looking at the clock and rewrite this
report I think we need a final version
of a report before this committee votes
on it and I think an interim report is
important but it is that an interm
report not a final report may I suggest
that this and I just want to add one
other thing I have offered to you on at
least three occasions that I would help
write that report okay and you did not
want that you you know you wanted to
proceed un not helpful not helpful may I
suggest that this committee recesses and
whatever you want to go into this final
report whether it's a word tweak or a
paragraph somewhere you come back with
those
words and a specific place where you
want it to go and we will
reconvene maybe in about 45 minutes this
should give you oh that's not then will
not happen then this will not happen
because we cannot schedule another
meeting we have today well actually we
could it's only Tuesday we could put it
in the calendar for when for next
week when is this report to November
around November 1 I don't choose to do
that that's that's your choice and I
respect your right to make that choice
unless others do if some would like to
do that
we can end this meeting and you can
suggest any changes you want and we will
put it in the calendar for next
Tuesday can I can I suggest you a
motion so I would I move that we adopt I
I make the following motion that we
adopt the interim
Report with the three three new
subcommittee reports plus the um uh memo
outlining the new legislation that has
been passed in part because of this uh
because of this committee's work okay uh
and that uh that the the uh interim
report be supplemented in addition to by
those those four things by the um
research that has been
uh provided by the uh office of
legislative services to to the
committee and that the final report also
indicate that the committee believes
that um additional
resources uh in in terms of law clerks
or other kinds of uh judicial assistance
uh
would
be uh strongly in uh recommended as
something that the legislature consider
that uh that be adopted as our final you
would give that
as an addendum that last point that we
will trust our beloved Vice chair to
write out she gets to fill out the blank
that we have voting in are you happy
with that can you do that I'm sure
yeah I'm fine I mean I would be fine
with I will do anything that um that the
committee uh chooses to do as long and
and do my part as I always have tried to
do as long as it in fact reflects what
the
committee agrees are the key findings
from the work that we have done over the
last two years
so I'm going to hold your Motion in OB
bance for a minute representative Lynn I
would add to it that in the interim
report wherever the word interim occurs
is is the word interim is dropped that's
needs to be part of the motion
um we have two possibilities number one
we adopt his motion and vote on it and
give you the chance to write out and it
will go in this report because we're
giving you the blank line to do it about
law clerks and additional judges and
things like that or you don't wish to
vote on that but really do want to come
back next week armed with everything you
want the final report to be those would
be the two possibilities is there a
third one no representa law I'll second
a motion which one his representative
Len's motion for all right let's discuss
it is not seconded let's discuss this
before we get for you want a second uh
well we don't want a second we don't
want to I don't want a second no can we
discuss his motion as alternative one
versus alternative two we come back next
week representative ball thank you
chairman person um if we're going to
consider his motion could we please just
make sure I lost the last sentence um of
what you put forward I have adopt and
then interim is in or out I'm not sure
um Report with three new subcommittee
reports Plus
the memo of the new legislation passed
and be supplemented by research provided
by the OS um to the committee and final
report also indicate that additional
resources of law clerks and addition
additional that's where I lost it I
don't know if you just ended
it I'm sorry that that um additional
that the that the final report recommend
that the legislature consider additional
resources for the for the
uh J for the Family Division of the
Circuit Court to
include uh law clerks or other uh
judicial assistants so you would make
that you are making that language in
this motion that she suggested right and
I and you know I mean I I make that
motion just be in the interest of sort
of hoping to get everybody together so
we could have a vote on this but I
I would completely defer if the if the
option were to to have representative
Smith uh draft some language which would
be much more articulate than what I've
just stated I'm sure um I would
certainly defer to that but in the
interest of you know if if what I've
sort of proposed is kind of good enough
so to speak um then the advantage of
doing what I've proposed is we could
just vote on it but I have no doubt that
representative Smith could do a better
job that forgot but all right any
further discussion on what is not quite
yet the first is the first alternative
but not yet a motion representative long
thank you Mr chairman um yeah I'm good
with the language that representative ly
says uh again to be up to uh Vice chair
whether she wanted to add language I
think it's important to add that we did
visit the circuit court and that we were
unanimous in the fact that uh um judges
needed help um however that may be
whether it's a clerk or
whatever I fine I have no Pro I'm happy
to add the language you just suggested
uh representative law um all right why
don't we do
this your
motion we
recess you write out that phrase so it
is your language we come back and vote
on the whole thing are you comfortable
with that or you now right now uh yeah
we I will start my next committee it
will be brief I I I thank you very much
but this is very important work I
believe and so that's no I'm not I'm not
going to do this in 20 minutes and I do
want to make the record clear um Mr
chair that I did right to you um perhaps
other people didn't make suggestions but
I did write and mentioned in their three
points that I thought were very
important and to be included in the
report so I did do do my part duly noted
at least once representative
mcbf thank you for recognizing me um so
I'm going just a little bit different
and I'm uncomfortable with um doing
thing I know I think we're all a little
bit uncomfortable but I do think there's
some points that are maybe we could add
in on page 10 of the report you ask for
specific there aren't numbers but it's
the subcommittee judicial training
education and supervision and
accountability um the second page of
that the top paragraph starts out
however charged with addressing the
obvious problems within the existing
structure there are certain threshold
issues right there I would suggest if
adding reaffirming the state
legislature's previous statutory
directives of one Court one one case one
judge so you had ask I may not have read
every email from every person but
believe me I did ask many times for
these things to be looked at well ahead
of today so I'm going to say this
report's good enough I'm going to say
we've been on the record there's
testimony there's video the court is
bending over backwards to try to go
along with what we're doing so we could
spend a long time redoing what we've
already voted on and I'm not I am not of
a mind to do that so
and may I follow up so I do respect that
I would just the only so that would be
one sentence there and then on that same
page the third paragraph where it talks
about judicial duties for judges to do
the judicial Duty they must have
staffing issues right there at the very
end of that I would suggest the uh
statement that um Justice Lynn had just
provided additional resources um are
strongly encouraged to be considered for
this purpose in future by Future legis
all right those I'm going to put an
alternative before you because I'm going
to bring this to a close and you may not
be happy so let me give you a choice
choice number one is what representative
Lynn has articulated that becomes the
motion we vote on the motion or we do
not vote on this but we have a meeting
in Thursday's calendar noticed for next
Tuesday at 9:30 to bring in what you
have submitted ahead of time those are
your two
choices uh can I going to take a stra
I'm going to take a straw poll of choice
one choice two Choice one
is it's the deadline of what that's for
interim study reports that's not for
this I did ask thank you but thank you
for for trying to do that choice
one we go to representative Lynn's
motion Choice two is we come back next
week straw
poll not counting except for what we do
next choice one we accept representative
Lynn's motion
hands Choice two we come back next week
the motion is we come back next week so
I will adjourn this committee the
suggestions you've just made the
suggestions Madam Vice chair you made
and anything else write them out
we will not discuss them for
91a but I think we'd like to see them
ahead of
time please um thank you very much for
your skill in handling this um Mr chair
trying to get us to yes assist
um could um I I it seems to me that left
un said is that I have a big
responsibility here between now and next
Tuesday and so I'm one wondering if my
colleagues would be kind enough to send
to
me suggestions that they have to be
included in a final report and I will
try to collect all of those and submit
them to uh the committee in advance of
next Tuesday for your
careful editing you'd like to collate
everything that comes in that is correct
so we get one document we and we'll have
one document and I'm hoping that that
would make it easier for everyone else
and I have to buy a car so yes it will
and you know I'm thinking what my
schedule is the next week but not as
important as this thank you is everyone
comfortable with
that I don't see any negatives so let's
do that and uh we will schedule our
final meeting for the final report for
next Tuesday at
9:30 here that way you can get outd door
knocking in the afternoon okay we are
adjourned thank you